This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Today we start out with something a little different. Love. The typical story. Love story. Kosti's Misa Takis says it's a typical love story, but it's not that typical. It began like this. In the early 2000s he was living in Greece, where he's from, when. I met a Spanish girl. Her name was Sandra Del Poso.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天我们从一个有点不同的故事开始。爱情。一个典型的故事。爱情故事。科斯蒂斯·米索塔基斯说这是一个典型的爱情故事，但又不那么典型。故事是这样开始的。21世纪初，他住在他的家乡希腊，当时……我遇到了一个西班牙女孩。她的名字叫桑德拉·德尔波索。
One thing brought the other, and we decided to, for me, I decided to give up everything and sell everything, and she decided also to give up her job. The two bought a small RV on eBay and started driving across Europe in the direction of Spain, where Sandra is from. She told me once, what do you think if we go to see my grandma? Sandra's grandmother lived in a small farming town in the northeast corner of Spain called Sodeto. Sodeto is one of about 300 little farming villages that the dictator Francisco Franco built in
事情一件接着一件，我们决定——对我来说，我决定放弃一切，卖掉所有东西，她也决定辞掉工作。两人在eBay上买了一辆小型房车，开始开车穿越欧洲，前往桑德拉的家乡西班牙。她有一次对我说，我们去看看我奶奶怎么样？桑德拉的祖母住在西班牙东北角一个叫索德托的小农耕镇。索德托是独裁者弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥在20世纪50年代在西班牙建造的约300个小农耕村庄之一。
Spain in the 1950s. He wanted to bring people and agriculture to some of the more desolate parts of the country. Producer Katie Mingle traveled to Sodeco, Spain recently. All the towns built during this time look similar and Sodeco is no exception. There's a church in the center of town and one bar, which is also the one restaurant, which is also the one place to hang out as far as I can tell.
他想把人口和农业带到该国一些更荒凉的地区。制片人凯蒂·明格尔最近去了西班牙的索德托。这一时期建造的所有城镇看起来都很相似，索德托也不例外。镇中心有一座教堂和一家酒吧，这也是唯一的餐厅，据我所知，也是唯一的聚会场所。
There are about 200 people who live in Sodetto permanently. All in homes built from stone, the color of sand, with red tile roofs. You know, the, the, you always see at the front, the main housing at the back is, uh, the, for the animals. That's coast East giving me a tour of this little town. After he and Sandra came to visit her grandmother here, they ended up staying. Yeah, so that's Sandra's house.
索德托常住人口约200人。所有的房子都是用沙色的石头建造的，配有红瓦屋顶。你知道，你总是能看到前面，后面的主要住房是……呃……给动物住的。那是科斯蒂斯在带我参观这个小镇。在他和桑德拉来看望她的祖母后，他们最终留了下来。是的，那是桑德拉的房子。
On the right, we have Sandra's house. Oh, and Sandra and Coasties, they're not together anymore. They actually broke up years ago. That was Edu, which is the new boyfriend of Sandra, the daddy of the two girls. After Costi and Sandra broke up, they both stayed in San Eto, went on with their lives, and then something really incredible happened. Something that brought everyone in this small town into the streets to celebrate all day and all night, into the wee hours of the morning.
右边是桑德拉的房子。哦，桑德拉和科斯蒂斯已经不在一起了。他们几年前就分手了。那是埃杜，桑德拉的新男友，两个女孩的爸爸。科斯蒂斯和桑德拉分手后，他们都留在了索德托，继续他们的生活，然后发生了一件非常不可思议的事情。这件事让这个小镇上的每个人都走上街头，整天整夜地庆祝，一直持续到清晨。
On December 22, 2011, almost everyone in this town went a piece of the biggest lottery jackpot in Spain. By chance, Kosti's Mitsotakis had found himself in the luckiest town in the world. I've never heard of an entire town winning the lottery. Maybe a group of friends or coworkers, but more often than not in the United States, the lottery winner is just one person. In Spain, though, they do lottery differently.
2011年12月22日，这个镇上几乎每个人都赢得了西班牙最大的彩票头奖。机缘巧合下，科斯蒂斯·米索塔基斯发现自己身处世界上最幸运的城镇。我从未听说过整个城镇都中了彩票。也许是一群朋友或同事，但在美国，彩票中奖者通常只有一个人。然而在西班牙，彩票的玩法不同。
First of all, it's a country-wide obsession. The Spanish lottery is a really big deal. They are not completely crazy. If you are not from Spain, you cannot understand it. You are surprised by the... There are people that are taking the day off to watch the lottery. There's more than one lottery in Spain, but the one that Kostis is talking about
首先，这是一种全国性的痴迷。西班牙彩票是一件大事。他们并不完全疯狂。如果你不是来自西班牙，你就无法理解。你会对……感到惊讶。有些人请假去看彩票开奖。西班牙不止一种彩票，但科斯蒂斯谈论的那种……
that people go nuts over. It's called La Loteria de Navidad, the Christmas lottery. And it has incredible buy-in from the population, about 75% of Spaniard's participate. The Christmas lottery is also the oldest running lottery in Spain, and one of the oldest in the world. The drawing has happened every single year since 1812.
人们为之疯狂的那种。它被称为“圣诞彩票”。它在民众中有极高的参与度，大约75%的西班牙人会参与。圣诞彩票也是西班牙历史最悠久的彩票，也是世界上最古老的彩票之一。自1812年以来，每年都会进行开奖。
This includes the years of the Spanish Civil War and all the way through the Franco dictatorship. For better or worse, lotteries have long been considered a useful way for governments to raise funds for things like infrastructure projects and public programs. Colonial America was basically built using lottery revenue. But in the early 1800s, opposition to the idea of lottery was growing all over the world,
这包括西班牙内战期间以及整个佛朗哥独裁统治时期。无论好坏，彩票长期以来一直被政府视为为基础设施项目和公共项目筹集资金的有用方式。殖民时期的美国基本上就是利用彩票收入建立起来的。但在19世纪初，世界各地对彩票理念的反对声日益高涨，
especially in Europe. Lotteries were, and still are, by the way, thought to be a regressive tax on the poor. Churches found lottery play to be blasphemous and superstitious. And intellectuals like Carl Marx thought that public lottery were a sinister instrument of the capitalist state, designed to convince the proletariat that there was an easy way to escape poverty.
尤其是在欧洲。顺便说一句，彩票当时被认为，现在仍然被认为是对穷人的一种累退税。教会认为买彩票是亵渎神明和迷信的行为。而像卡尔·马克思这样的知识分子认为，公共彩票是资本主义国家的一种险恶工具，旨在让无产阶级相信有一种逃避贫困的捷径。
In 1826, the British outright banned the lottery for nearly 100 years. And in 1862, Spain responded to the opposition as well, by redesigning their national lottery so that it wouldn't take as much money from the poor. They decided to make the tickets very expensive. And what the rationale was that if these are an affordable, for people won't buy them.
1826年，英国彻底禁止了彩票近100年。1862年，西班牙也通过重新设计国家彩票来回应这种反对，这样它就不会从穷人那里拿走那么多钱。他们决定让彩票变得非常昂贵。其理由是，如果这些彩票负担不起，人们就不会买。
That's Bertha Estavevillart. She's an economist at York University in Toronto who has studied Spain's Christmas lottery. She says the Spanish government figured that if they set the price of lottery tickets really high, only rich people would buy them. But that's not how it worked out. What happened is, instead of people not buying lottery anymore, they decided to turn to their networks and start a syndicate playing. People began syndicate playing or playing in groups, and the lottery became more popular than ever.
那是伯莎·埃斯塔维利亚特。她是多伦多约克大学的经济学家，研究过西班牙的圣诞彩票。她说，西班牙政府认为，如果他们把彩票价格定得很高，只有富人会买。但事实并非如此。发生的情况是，人们并没有停止购买彩票，而是决定转向他们的社交网络，开始联合购买。人们开始联合起来或分组购买，彩票变得比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。
So people in the same neighborhood or family or friends, they would buy one ticket by putting together their money. together their money. The Christmas lottery works like this. There are 100,000 possible numbers, ranging from 0 to 99,999. When you go to the lottery office, they'll tell you what numbers are available in your area, and you pick one. But it's really expensive to own an entire number, like tens of thousands of euros.
所以同一个社区、家庭或朋友会凑钱买一张彩票。圣诞彩票是这样运作的：有100,000个可能的号码，范围从0到99,999。当你去彩票办公室时，他们会告诉你你所在地区有哪些号码可用，然后你选一个。但拥有一个完整的号码非常昂贵，需要数万欧元。
What is much more common is that an organization will buy a share of a number and then sell off even smaller shares to individuals. Five-year-oh shares or two-year-oh shares, thousands of people may own small fractions of the same number. The smaller the share you have, the less you get of the total jackpot if your number should win. And one of the things that this has done is to turn this Christmas lottery into a huge social event.
更常见的是，一个组织会购买一个号码的份额，然后将更小的份额卖给个人。五欧元或两欧元的份额，成千上万的人可能拥有同一个号码的一小部分。你拥有的份额越小，如果你的号码中奖，你获得的头奖总额就越少。这件事带来的结果之一就是将圣诞彩票变成了一场盛大的社交活动。
Local organizations sell tickets at a markup for fundraisers, so your soccer team might be selling shares of a number. The school your kids go to may be selling shares of a different number. Most Spaniards have a stack of tickets, all different tiny shares of different numbers that they've been talked into buying by someone. The numbers go on sale in the summer, and then on December 22nd, all of Spain tunes in to watch the drawing. Every year has been done the same way in the same theater in Madrid. It starts out, I think, at 8 o'clock in the morning, and the TVs and the radios are always everywhere on, showing this thing.
当地组织以加价方式出售彩票以进行筹款，所以你的足球队可能在卖某个号码的份额。你孩子上的学校可能在卖另一个号码的份额。大多数西班牙人都有一叠彩票，都是他们被别人说服购买的不同号码的微小份额。彩票在夏天开始发售，然后在12月22日，全西班牙都会收看开奖直播。每年都在马德里的同一个剧院以同样的方式进行。我想是从早上8点开始，电视和收音机到处都在播放这个节目。
If you turned on Spanish TV that morning, here's what you'd see. There's a stage, and on it are two giant golden orbs. One contains balls with all the possible lottery numbers printed on them. The other smaller orb has balls with the prize money amounts, while one orb spits out a number. The other drops down the corresponding prize amount. After the balls drop, a couple of Catholic school kids in their uniforms sing the numbers and prizes out loud in a kind of Gregorian chant. The whole thing goes on for several tedious hours. And the kids aren't particularly great singers. $14,426.
如果你那天早上打开西班牙电视，你会看到这样的场景：舞台上有两个巨大的金球。一个装有印着所有可能彩票号码的球。另一个较小的球装有奖金金额，当一个球吐出一个号码时，另一个球会掉下相应的奖金金额。球掉落后，几个穿着制服的天主教学校的孩子会用一种类似格列高利圣咏的方式大声唱出号码和奖金。整个过程持续了几个乏味的小时。而且孩子们唱得并不是特别好。14,426美元。
Me, sorry. I have to say that. $14,380. There are a bunch of small prize amounts that drop, but at some point the orbs spit out the biggest prize of the day and its corresponding number. This big prize is called El Gordo, the fat one. The total jackpot for El Gordo can be close to a billion dollars. I'm so happy to see you again! I'm so happy to see you again! I'm so happy to see you again!
我，抱歉。我必须说那个。14,380美元。有很多小奖金掉落，但在某个时刻，球会吐出当天最大的奖项及其对应的号码。这个大奖被称为“胖子奖”。“胖子奖”的总奖金可以接近十亿美元。我很高兴再次见到你！我很高兴再次见到你！我很高兴再次见到你！
I'm so happy to see you again! But it's almost certain that the winning number isn't held by a single individual. It's held by hundreds or even thousands of people who probably all live in the same geographic region of Spain. Reporters scrambled to find out where the winning number was sold. And on December 22nd, 2011, everyone looked to a little farming town in the northeast corner of the country. I got a phone call from a friend of mine that he was on the train. That's Coasties again. He was telling me that something is going on in Sardeto
我很高兴再次见到你！但几乎可以肯定，中奖号码不是由个人持有的。它由数百甚至数千人持有，他们可能都住在西班牙的同一个地理区域。记者们争先恐后地想找出中奖号码是在哪里售出的。2011年12月22日，所有人的目光都投向了该国东北角的一个小农耕镇。我接到了一个朋友的电话，他当时在火车上。那是科斯蒂斯。他告诉我索德托发生了一些事情，
because I'm in the train and everybody's on the phone talking on the phone and I hear all the time Sardeto, Sardeto, Sardeto. 58,268. That was the lottery number that had won El Gordo. The winning tickets had been sold all over Soretto by the Housewives Association, a group of women who host parties and activities in town. The association sold lottery tickets door-to-door for six euros, five euros for the lottery share and one euro for their fundraising. Hola, soy Maricarmen L'Ambéa.
因为我在火车上，每个人都在打电话，我一直听到索德托、索德托、索德托。58,268。那是赢得“胖子奖”的彩票号码。中奖彩票是由家庭主妇协会在索德托各地售出的，这是一群在镇上举办派对和活动的女性。该协会以6欧元的价格挨家挨户出售彩票，其中5欧元用于彩票份额，1欧元用于筹款。你好，我是玛丽卡门·兰比亚。
Yo escogí el número de la lotería que tuve. Hi, I'm Maricarmen L'Ambéa, and I chose the winning number in Sodeto when I was the secretary of the Housewives Association. When Marie Carmen heard that their number had won El Gordo, she started calling friends. No one could believe it. On a PA system that the town normally only used to announce water shortages, El Gordo, she started calling friends. No one could believe it.
我选择了中奖的彩票号码。嗨，我是玛丽卡门·兰比亚，当我是家庭主妇协会的秘书时，我选择了索德托的中奖号码。当玛丽卡门听说他们的号码赢得了“胖子奖”时，她开始给朋友们打电话。没人敢相信。在一个通常只用于宣布缺水的广播系统上，她开始给朋友们打电话。没人敢相信。
On a PA system that the town normally only used to announce water shortages, the mayor came on and said, Congratulations, Sodeto, we have just one military come to the plaza to celebrate. That experience, you can't really explain it. If you didn't live it, you can't imagine. If you had been there in the moment, you would have thought
在一个通常只用于宣布缺水的广播系统上，镇长走上来说，恭喜索德托，我们刚刚赢得了“胖子奖”，请到广场庆祝。那种经历，你真的无法解释。如果你没有亲身经历，你无法想象。如果你当时在那里，你会认为
these people have gone completely crazy. The residents of Sodato frantically searched for their tickets. Had they bought one from the housewives? Each six-year-old ticket, the housewives at Salt, was now worth 100,000 euros. How many did each person have? Soon the entire town was congregated in the fauna. People chanted their winning number as cars drove through the streets honking their horns. We are the best! We are the best! Yeah!
这些人完全疯了。索德托的居民疯狂地寻找他们的彩票。他们从家庭主妇那里买了吗？家庭主妇们卖出的每张6欧元的彩票，现在价值10万欧元。每个人有多少张？很快整个小镇都聚集在广场上。人们高呼他们的中奖号码，汽车鸣着喇叭穿过街道。我们是最棒的！我们是最棒的！耶！
Anna, the bartender, had won. Paco, the farmer and his wife, Marisol, the hairdresser, had won. Rosa, the mayor of the town, had won. It seemed that every single resident of the small town of Sodeto had bought a lottery ticket from the housewives and won a piece of El Gordo. The whole village, everyone, everyone except one. Yet there was one person who didn't have a ticket.
酒保安娜赢了。农民帕科和他的妻子、理发师玛丽索尔赢了。镇长罗莎赢了。似乎索德托小镇的每一位居民都从家庭主妇那里买了彩票，并赢得了“胖子奖”的一部分。整个村庄，每个人，除了一个人。然而，有一个人没有彩票。
And who was it? That was me. Coasties did not have a ticket. Coasties who had moved to the town for love and stayed even after he broke up with his Spanish girlfriend, Sandra. Who yes, had a ticket. Costies lived on the edge of town, and somehow the housewives had missed him when they went knocking on doors.
那个人是谁？那是我。科斯蒂斯没有彩票。科斯蒂斯为了爱情搬到这个小镇，即使在与西班牙女友桑德拉分手后也留了下来。是的，她有彩票。科斯蒂斯住在镇边，不知何故，家庭主妇们敲门时错过了他。
They drove everywhere except at my place, which they didn't do it on purpose. It just is the only one which is outside, you know, from the village, so they do feel a little bit guilty. The people of Sodeto were not the only ones to win on the number 58,268 in 2011. A few thousand other people also had small shares of the number, mostly scattered around in towns nearby. The total jackpot that year for El Gordo was about 750 million euros, but it was divided by thousands of people. And so De To, the people who bought more tickets, got more money, and everyone got at least 100,000 euros. Everyone except co-stees.
他们去了所有地方，除了我家，他们不是故意的。只是因为它是唯一一个在村子外面的，你知道，所以他们确实感到有点内疚。2011年，索德托的居民并不是唯一赢得58,268这个号码的人。还有几千人也拥有该号码的小份额，大多分散在附近的城镇。那一年“胖子奖”的总奖金约为7.5亿欧元，但被数千人瓜分了。在索德托，买更多彩票的人得到了更多的钱，每个人至少得到了10万欧元。除了科斯蒂斯，每个人都赢了。
Ramil, what's up? Six years later, co-stees still lives in Saratdo. He and Sandra are good friends now. She lives in the center of town, and he just outside of it, in a barn that he's turned into a house that still feels kind of like a barn. He has a couple of big German shepherds. You can hear one of them jumping into my mic.
拉米尔，怎么了？六年过去了，科斯蒂斯仍然住在索德托。他和桑德拉现在是好朋友。她住在镇中心，而他住在镇外，在一个他改建成房子的谷仓里，感觉仍然像个谷仓。他有几只德国牧羊犬。你可以听到其中一只跳进我的麦克风。
When I ask Cosius if he felt or still feels any regret or jealousy about not having a ticket, he laughs like it's a ridiculous question. No, nothing. For a while after Soetto's win, reporters swarmed the little town. They especially wanted to talk with Kostis, the one unlucky guy who was left out of the lottery. But Kostis doesn't feel unlucky.
当我问科斯蒂斯他是否感到或仍然感到后悔或嫉妒没有买彩票时，他笑得好像这是一个荒谬的问题。不，什么都没有。在索德托中奖后的一段时间里，记者们蜂拥而至这个小镇。他们特别想和科斯蒂斯谈谈，那个唯一被排除在彩票之外的倒霉蛋。但科斯蒂斯并不觉得自己倒霉。
In fact, if anything, he feels like he got something that day too. He's a filmmaker, and the day the town won the lottery, he grabbed his camera and went to the plaza. The moment that that happened, it was literally like somebody was giving me a script in my hands. He filmed all the celebrating, and he's been filming ever since. He says it's been really interesting to see what happens when a whole town gets wealth all at once. The whole thing is like a social experiment with really fast results to study and see what an event like this can do to people. He's not always for good.
事实上，如果有的话，他觉得那天他也得到了一些东西。他是一名电影制作人，在小镇中奖的那天，他拿起摄像机去了广场。那一刻发生的时候，简直就像有人把剧本交到了我手里。他拍摄了所有的庆祝活动，从那以后他一直在拍摄。他说，看到整个城镇同时获得财富时会发生什么，这真的很有趣。整个事情就像一个有着非常快速结果的社会实验，可以研究和观察这样的事件会对人们产生什么影响。并不总是好的。
Costa thinks the people in Sarato have become a little more insular since the win, more focused on the nuclear family and less on the town as a community. You do see how he's affecting how they have changed, how they have closed. Before that, all the doors were constantly open. The way he talks about it makes me wonder if the people in the town will like the film when they see it. But Coastie says he thinks they will, mostly. Maybe a few small things they might not like it, but that's reality.
科斯蒂斯认为，自中奖以来，索德托的人们变得更加封闭了，更关注核心家庭，而对作为社区的城镇关注较少。你确实能看到他是如何影响他们的改变，他们是如何封闭的。在那之前，所有的门总是开着的。他谈论这件事的方式让我怀疑镇上的人在看到这部电影时是否会喜欢它。但科斯蒂斯说他认为他们会，大部分会。也许有一些小地方他们可能不喜欢，但这就是现实。
One thing about Sarato, there are birds, a lot of them. Luckily this is also one of the things I'm able to say in Spanish. Pajados, sí. And yetchas. Another thing about Soretto, it's hot. Marie Carmen, the former secretary of the Housewives Association, tells me it's not usually this hot until later in the summer. This heat, she says, I just can't with this heat.
关于索德托的一件事，那里有鸟，很多鸟。幸运的是，这也是我能用西班牙语说的事情之一。鸟，是的。还有那些。关于索德托的另一件事，它很热。家庭主妇协会的前秘书玛丽卡门告诉我，通常夏天晚些时候才会这么热。她说，这种热，我真的受不了这种热。
As we walk around, Sodeto, she's pointing out a few houses that have been fixed up with lottery money. But mostly Marie Carmen says, the town hasn't changed that much. So, that was a town of farmers and some of them installed new irrigation systems or bought new tractors. Some people made modest additions to their homes, but nothing that extravagant. Kielo, Vania, Terva. Unlike Costa's, Marie Carmen hasn't noticed the town being more closed off since the lottery. She thinks there have been some little jealousies here and there, not everyone won the same amount.
当我们走在索德托时，她指出了几栋用彩票钱修缮过的房子。但玛丽卡门说，小镇并没有太大变化。所以，那是一个农民小镇，有些人安装了新的灌溉系统或买了新的拖拉机。有些人对他们的房子进行了适度的扩建，但没有什么太奢侈的。不像科斯蒂斯，玛丽卡门并没有注意到自彩票以来小镇变得更加封闭。她认为这里偶尔会有一些小嫉妒，毕竟不是每个人赢的金额都一样。
But overall, she thinks it's been an incredible thing for everyone in this little working-class town to live without the worry of debt. She's been battling cancer, which keeps going away and coming back, and the money's allowed her to stop working and not worry. For me personally, the lottery has just brought a sense of calm. I don't know, like, to have the day to day cover it, you know?
但总的来说，她认为对于这个小镇上的每个人来说，能够不用担心债务地生活是一件不可思议的事情。她一直在与癌症作斗争，病情反复，这笔钱让她可以停止工作，不用担心。对我个人来说，彩票只带来了一种平静感。我不知道，就像，能够应付日常开销，你知道吗？
And that's the thing with this Syndicate-style lottery, unlike the Powerball Trackpot, which heaps hundreds of millions on one or two lonely winners. The money from the Christmas lottery gets divvied up among thousands of people, and they don't generally win enough to buy mansions and yachts. They win enough to pay off their debts, maybe buy a Honda Civic. The lottery brings wealth to a whole geographic area and distributes it relatively evenly, at least among those lucky enough to have a ticket. After a short walk, Marie Carmen and I arrive at the new office of the Housewives Association,
这就是这种联合式彩票的特点，不像强力球头奖，它将数亿美元堆在这一两个孤独的赢家身上。圣诞彩票的钱被分给成千上万的人，他们通常赢的钱不足以购买豪宅和游艇。他们赢的钱足够还清债务，也许买一辆本田思域。彩票将财富带给整个地理区域，并相对均匀地分配它，至少在那些幸运地拥有彩票的人中间是这样。走了一小段路后，玛丽卡门和我到达了家庭主妇协会的新办公室，
which now, to be more modern, is officially called the Women's Association, but everyone still seems to call it the Housewives Association. Back in 2011, when they were selling lottery tickets, the group kept for for themselves, which ended up winning them 400,000 euros. At the time, enough to cover their budget for the next 200 years. With all the new money, they fixed up an old school building in town and made it into their office slash community center. It has a nice kitchen for parties, a laundry room and a fitness center.
为了更现代化，现在正式称为妇女协会，但每个人似乎仍然称它为家庭主妇协会。回到2011年，当他们出售彩票时，该组织为自己保留了一些，最终赢得了40万欧元。当时，这足以支付他们未来200年的预算。有了这笔新钱，他们修缮了镇上的一栋旧校舍，把它变成了他们的办公室兼社区中心。它有一个漂亮的派对厨房、一个洗衣房和一个健身中心。
You see, all of this was made with lottery money. This living room was built, the kitchen, and the association gave coasties some money for his film. We gave him... I don't remember how much, if it was 15,000 euros or how much. I don't know, it was a good bit. But she also mentions that he hasn't finished it yet, and everyone is waiting.
你看，所有这些都是用彩票钱做的。这个客厅是建的，厨房也是，协会还给了科斯蒂斯一些钱拍电影。我们给了他……我不记得是多少了，是1.5万欧元还是多少。我不知道，是一笔不错的数目。但她也提到他还没有拍完，每个人都在等。
No, it still hasn't come out in theaters or anything yet. The people here in the village are waiting, like, what's up, we gave you money. Marie Carmen isn't the only one to mention this to me. It actually seems to be the talk of the town. A little later that day I run into a group of older guys. When I tell them I met with Coasties, one of them says, The one who made the movie.
不，它还没有在电影院上映或什么的。村里的人都在等，就像，怎么回事，我们给了你钱。玛丽卡门并不是唯一一个向我提到这一点的人。这似乎成了镇上的谈资。那天晚些时候，我遇到了一群老伙计。当我告诉他们我见过科斯蒂斯时，其中一个人说，那个拍电影的人。
But he hasn't even come out with it yet. I tell him I think it'll be another year before the film is finished and he says, Okay, I'll take a mordinko. But it's already been five. Another guy chimed in and says, Coastist didn't win the lottery, but he's done quite well for himself. He says he's been getting paid for all the television interviews he's done.
但他甚至还没把它拿出来。我告诉他，我想电影完成还需要一年，他说，好吧，我会再等一会儿。但已经五年了。另一个人插话说，科斯蒂斯没中彩票，但他自己做得相当不错。他说他从他做的所有电视采访中都得到了报酬。
Then they talk about how much he's been getting paid. Mucho dinero. Mucho. ¿A qué le dieron? Ah, no lo sabía. No, lo hago. For the record, Coastist told me he's never been paid for any interviews. Conspiracy theories aside, I got the feeling the people in Sardeto liked Coastist, the strange Greek artist who lives on the outskirts of town. But I also wondered if they see him as an outsider, and if the lottery has made this even more pronounced.
然后他们谈论他得到了多少报酬。很多钱。很多。他们给了他什么？啊，我不知道。不，我没有。郑重声明，科斯蒂斯告诉我他从未因任何采访获得报酬。阴谋论暂且不论，我感觉到索德托的人们喜欢科斯蒂斯，那个住在镇郊的奇怪的希腊艺术家。但我也想知道他们是否把他视为局外人，以及彩票是否让这一点变得更加明显。
When I asked Marie Carmen about this, she says, no, he's one of us. We just wish he'd come out with that movie. Economists have long struggled to figure out why people play the lottery. It's not a rational investment of your money. The odds of winning are terrible, worse than Blackjack, worse than slot machines, worse odds than any other form of gambling, and yet it's the most popular form of gambling. But in Spain, it's pretty obvious why people play this lottery. It's a social thing to do.
当我问玛丽卡门这个问题时，她说，不，他是我们的一员。我们只是希望他能把那部电影拍出来。经济学家们长期以来一直在努力弄清楚为什么人们会买彩票。这不是对你金钱的理性投资。中奖的几率很糟糕，比二十一点差，比老虎机差，比任何其他形式的赌博几率都差，但它却是最受欢迎的赌博形式。但在西班牙，人们玩这种彩票的原因很明显。这是一种社交活动。
You buy a ticket because the Housewives Association will pester you until you do it. You buy tickets because your friends are buying tickets. You buy because you don't want to be that one guy in town who doesn't win. You don't want to be coasties. The Housewives Association continues to choose a number each year for the Christmas lottery and sell tickets in Soretto and in the surrounding little towns. And while they used to knock on doors for months, they don't have to do that anymore. Now the people come to them and tickets sell out in a few days.
你买彩票是因为家庭主妇协会会一直缠着你，直到你买为止。你买彩票是因为你的朋友在买。你买是因为你不想成为镇上那个唯一没中奖的人。你不想成为科斯蒂斯。家庭主妇协会每年继续为圣诞彩票选择一个号码，并在索德托及周边小镇出售彩票。虽然他们过去几个月都要挨家挨户敲门，但现在不需要了。现在人们主动找他们，彩票几天内就卖光了。
They were lucky once and they could be again, people say. And no one wants to be left out. 99% Invisible was produced this week by our senior producer Katie Mingle, Mix and Tech Production by Sharif Usif, the digital director is Kurt Colstead. The rest of the team includes Delaney Hall, Avery Trollman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Wars. Find out more about Coastie's movie, which he's working on with his film partner Laura Swarinson at KwondoToco.com.
人们说，他们曾经幸运过，可能还会再幸运一次。没有人想被落下。《99%隐形》本周由我们的高级制片人凯蒂·明格尔制作，混音和技术制作由谢里夫·乌西夫负责，数字总监是库尔特·科尔斯特德。团队其他成员包括德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特罗尔曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎和我罗曼·马尔斯。在KwondoToco.com上了解更多关于科斯蒂斯的电影，他正在与他的电影合作伙伴劳拉·斯瓦林森合作。
We'll put a link on our website because I am not going to spell it for you. While you're there, check out some beautiful animations of this story by Benjamin Stark. Music in this episode was composed by Jenny Conley Driesos, John Newfeld, and Nate Query. They were a part of the team that also scored the Genie Chance story and toured live with us. They are the best. We had additional songs composed by our own, Sean Rial.
我们会在我们的网站上放一个链接，因为我不会为你拼写它。当你在那里时，看看本杰明·斯塔克为这个故事制作的一些精美动画。本集音乐由珍妮·康利·德里索斯、约翰·纽菲尔德和内特·奎里创作。他们也是为《精灵机会》故事配乐并与我们一起巡演的团队的一部分。他们是最棒的。我们还有由我们自己的肖恩·里亚尔创作的额外歌曲。
Carmen Vidal did the English voiceover from Marie Carmen. Special thanks to Roberto Garvia and Zach Frolic. We are a project of radio-topia and KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show in joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Org. Or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want to read Kurt's story about that time, we tested guided missiles for
卡门·维达尔为玛丽卡门做了英语配音。特别感谢罗伯托·加维亚和扎克·弗罗利克。我们是旧金山Radio-topia和KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg。或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也可以。但如果你想读库尔特关于我们测试导弹用于邮政递送的那次故事，
postal delivery. That really happened. You can find out all about it on our website atepia.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那真的发生了。你可以在我们的网站atepia.org上找到所有相关信息。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。